you know i can't not ask you about the
mcu if we're going down your filmography
here
so correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
i believe you've said that that
opportunity came your way as a voice
acting gig and you didn't know what the
project was
yeah when you found out that it was an
mcu film is there any
apprehension that comes with that
essentially
knowing that the second you commit to
that you are also committing
to getting asked about it in like right
now you know it did of course i had to
ask myself
i think for any job an actor has to ask
themselves what does this say
about the kind of work i want to do what
message is this sending to the world
because for me number one is always the
writing a number two is whether it
challenges me in a particular way
and then number three of course has to
be what are the considerations more
broadly for my career because
frankly if you want to have longevity
you have to think about it and so there
was
there was some idea of having come from
a pretty um
auteur television world to jumping into
the most commercial project that ever
existed
there was a little bit of soul searching
about that but ultimately i had done
motion capture for video games and
graduate school
and it was a really it was a really
unusual opportunity that
most actors would kill for and who am i
to say no to that
um but the process was just unlike
anything i've ever done
so um it had its own challenges you know
and yes i get asked about that i've
signed more autographs for that movie
than i have for all of my other work
combined oh i thought i could imagine
and it i i imagine i imagine it must be
frustrating to have certain other films
not get that same attention but at the
same time i just have so much respect
for that franchise that's just
they're really smart and really they're
trafficking some really large ideas and
let's face it
they're our greek gods there's a
spiritual life
that people choose when they look to
those franchises with such reverence
it's not just about commercialism it's
about gods and goddesses
it's about something bigger than us